this is my favorite story of the week
shyla buff
has converted to catholicism
that alone i love charla buff who's had
some problems who like a lot of actors
has been kind of eccentric and explored
lots of different things shyla buff has
converted to catholicism he was doing a
movie about padre pio who's a great
catholic saint
and
my favorite part is the reason why shia
labeouf
converted to catholicism the holy spirit
would probably be reason number one
reason number two
because of the traditional latin mass
latin mass affects me deeply
deeply and okay because it feels like
they're not selling me a car
and when i go to some mass with the
guitars and stuff and i'm from you know
santa ines right so that's where i was
catechized and there's a lot of guitar
playing and there's a lot of like what
feels like
um
like they're trying to sell me on an
idea i was always an agnostic even when
i was a sam harris ted talk you know
christopher hitchens guy
which is who i was before i fell in um
um
it um i always had a belief but i never
had like a connection latin mass gave me
something where i felt connected uh
which took me out of belief into
connection belief kept me
you know i had belief because that's the
rational
logical
it's not logical or rational to be
atheist if you really go deep enough you
get to the big bang and then then you're
screwed again you know you have to
account for it somehow which puts you in
a belief situation right but
too much of that logic and that too much
of that rationale takes me out of
feeling which takes me out of connection
so he's describing it at the end in this
kind of actory way which is he this
immersive experience he's had at the
traditional latin mass but i i also love
that that line at the beginning
i love the latin mass i'm drawn to the
latin mass why is that because i feel
like they're not trying to sell me a car
it's so true the mass that existed for
most of the last 2000 years until 1970
when a bunch of boomer libs
decided to destroy the liturgy not just
the boomers it was even the generation
before
when that when that happened
and then they instituted all the weird
guitar churches and all that kind of
stuff uh it drove people away it drove
tens of thousands of priests away it
drove
countless laity away because they feel
like
all of a sudden they're just being sold
something you know the priest is no
longer facing the altar and we're all
facing it together but the priest is
facing you and he's doing a little soft
shoe and he's telling yucky yuck jokes
and it makes it all about you sure but
you go to church
to get out of everything being all about
you everything's all about you for your
whole week probably you go to church to
experiencing some to experience
something different outside of yourself
outside of the world you go there for an
experience of heaven and that's what
charlotte buff is describing he says i'm
i feel like i'm let in on a secret like
i'm part of something like i'm really
witnessing a miracle take place
and it's not just a show
to to entertain me or to
please me i love it
probably it's the lib liberal kind of
church reformers who are going to be the
hardest hit because it turns out the
youths don't want squishiness and
electric guitars they want truth they
want orthodoxy they want smells and
bells and a glimpse of heaven that's
what they want i love it this is my this
is wonderful stuff welcome to the church
shia labeouf michael i think you know a
question i'm going to ask you because i
bet you've been bombarded with this
question but why did you have to bring
the little league into politics the way
you did i mean
when i was 12 years old if i hit
somebody in the head with a baseball i
would be traumatized i'd just be
thinking the worst i'd be terrified that
that kid was injured you have to go to
the hospital i mean you are shaking and
terrified you're a kid and for another
kid to come up the team like from the
other team to come up and maybe give me
a hug or let me know is okay
as a kid
when you're immature and you're still
learning about life i'm down for it um i
just want to know do you
want to take back anything you said
about that incident
or do you stand by everything you said
even though i know that what you said
the principle about you know being tough
applies to politics for sure just want
to give you an opportunity to either
defend yourself or to
explain yourself a little bit more i'm
very curious all right thanks have a
good one
i stand by everything i said
i haven't been bombarded on that for
those who missed it a week or two ago on
the show i played this clip that had
gone viral of the little league world
series and the pitcher kid beamed the
batter in the head and the kid went down
but he was okay you know knocked his
helmet a little but it still bounced off
the helmet and then the kid takes his
first base and then the first baseman
walks over to the pitcher and gives him
a hug
and i said man i bet these are such good
kids they're such good kids
they it's wonderful that's a great act
of friendship to do that i hope these
kids go out and get an ice cream cone
after the game but
the game is not the place for that
there's a time for every purpose under
heaven a time for war a time for peace
a time to embrace a time to refrain from
embracing and the game is not the place
for that and so you're making the point
yeah sure we got to be tough in politics
but we shouldn't come on we shouldn't be
tough on the little league field no that
actually that's the point of little
league that's the point of introducing
kids to sports that's the point of
education is to model the right behavior
for them and teach them
the appropriate times for behavior
and so yeah if the if the pitcher had
knocked the kid down and he were taken
out on a stretcher maybe that's a
different circumstance but he knocked
the kid down kid got right up dusted
himself off took first base
the pitcher was still a little shaken up
about it okay
but you you've the the purpose of these
sports is to is to
teach kids how to work through these
kinds of things
and how to maintain their composure and
how to
follow the rules and how to play the
game
and how to be competitive when you're
supposed to be competitive
and how to be sportsmanly when
when the game is over
and the the problem here is not that the
kid who got beamed with the baseball was
nice to the other kid the problem was
the timing there's a time and a place
for everything that was not the place
for it so no stand by it i wouldn't
punish the kids for it
you know there you might say oh that was
very nice of you johnny but it's
actually not the place for that
place for that is at the ice cream
parlor or the soda fountain after the
game i'm glad you like that clip now
look we hit a million subscribers on
youtube i appreciate that that's really
great that we did it
now we got to hit a billion a trillion a
quadrillion who knows sky's the limit
ring the bell subscribe we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you